it was romance that put everybody out of  business and the thing that bothers me  about romance is it lacks practicality I  hate when I go and speak at these  companies or agencies and they go  he's a disruptor and he's a real  disrupter areas Gary and I get up there  I'm like I'm not a [ __ ] disruptor I'm  the most practically [ __ ] guy in this  room you know what I think's disruptive  trying to sell a twenty five year old in  2016  something threw a [ __ ] television  commercial that's disruptive that's  [ __ ] insanity and you know what  bothers me the most and I'll end with  this you know this when you walk out of  this [ __ ] hole you know this it's  what you do every [ __ ] day as a  normal human  it's what your parents are doing every  day you see it right in your face but  because this is what you do for a living  you trick yourself when you walk through  these doors that's wrong justice justice  thank you